friede freude Schneeballschlacht die
Ampelkoalition gab sich harmonisch bei
ihrer Kabinettsklausur auf dem Land der
Twist vor allem zwischen FDP und Grünen
bei den Themen Verkehr und Heizen der
wurde dabei nicht gelöst es geht ja auch
um ganz grundsätzliches erreicht man die
Energiewende durch Verordnungen oder mit
Vertrauen in neue Technologien was darf
man Bürgern zumuten und was lässt sich
realistisch umsetzen angesichts fehlende
Handwerker Streit um Verbrenner und
Heizungen zur notverbot unser Thema in
der Phönix Runde
[Musik]
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste lisa badum
ist bei uns sie ist im Bundestag für die
Grünen und Obfrau im Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie ihr Wahlkreis
liegt im fränkischen Bamberg ich begrüße
Jana Schimke Mitglied des Bundestages
für die CDU und stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende der mittelstands- und
Wirtschaftsunion ihr Wahlkreis liegt in
Brandenburg südlich von Berlin herzlich
willkommen Volker quaschning Professor
für das Fachgebiet regenerative
Energiesysteme an der Hochschule für
Technik und Wirtschaft HTW Berlin und er
ist mit Initiator der scientis for
future und ich begrüße Sven Heppner er
ist beim Verband die Familienunternehmer
zuständig für die Energiepolitik und
geschäftsführender Gesellschafter des
elektronikunternehmens Werner wird
Holding in Hamburg herzlich willkommen
in allen Frau bardum es gab nach außen
hin sehr klare Harmonie es wurde gesagt
wir haben uns untergehakt als als
Koalition als Dreier Bündnis aber dann
gab es in Brüssel doch
Ärger über die Liberalen vor allem
Dingen die nämlich ich das geplante aus
für den Verbrennungsmotor erstmal
gestoppt haben jetzt hat der
Bundeskanzler auch gesagt der findet das
ganz in Ordnung was heißt denn das für
die Ampel ja also ich bin sicher dass
wir uns in der Koalition noch einigen
werden und auch die
EU-Ratspräsidentschaft arbeitet an einer
Lösung die Abstimmung ist erstmal
verschoben aber wird wieder auf die Top
kommen bisschen ärgerlich war natürlich
das Verfahren weil wir hatten uns in der
Koalition ja bereits geeinigt dass wir
den Verbrenner aus 2035 zustimmen
Kommission EU-Parlament und Regierungen
hatten sich darauf verständigt und es
ist eben sehr unüblich sehr kurz vorher
da noch seine Meinung zu ändern aber ich
bin guter Dinge dass im Gespräch mit
Herrn Wissing dass wir in der Koalition
das lösen können und da auch europäisch
entsprechend solide
verantwortungsbewusst auftreten können
als als Deutschland
Liberalen Europäern und es gibt auch
jetzt andere Länder die sagen ja wenn
die Deutschen dass die mal machen wird
ist auch nicht auch also was stimmt ist
das im Europäischen Parlament die
FDP-Fraktion also die heißt dort anders
aber eben die dortige FDP zum ganz
großen Teil ohne die deutschen
Mitglieder diesen Verbrenner aus auch
zugestimmt haben also da sieht man es
ist irgendwie verquer wir müssen zu
einer Lösung kommen aber bestimmt ist
für uns das Klimaschutzgesetz wir werden
einer Woche die neuen emissionszahlen
haben und da wird ganz klar rauskommen
dass wir bei Verkehr leider die Ziele
wieder reißen im letzten Jahr dass wir
mehr tun müssen und dass wir auch sehr
ein weiteres Thema bei Gebäude auf einem
guten Weg sind aber auch noch einiges
anstoßen müssen und ich glaube als
Regierung und das werden alle
Koalitionspartner zu sehen auch die
Opposition die ist Klimaschutzgesetz ja
verabschiedet hat also das bin ich auch
sehr dankbar dass die große Koalition
ist auf dem Weg gebracht hat wir müssen
diese Klimaziele einhalten und da sind
jetzt entsprechende Maßnahmen einfach zu
tätigen aber würden sie sich da ein
Machtwort das Kanzlers wünschen als
grüne
ich glaube wir müssen es einfach
politisch diskutieren anhand der
Gesetzeslage und die ist klar wir haben
das Klimaschutzgesetz einzuhalten und
wir haben einfach klare Vorgaben zu
machen den Autoherstellern in der
Vergangenheit hat sich gezeigt dass die
flottengrenzwerte also das ist ja das
was bis mit dem Verbrenner aus verbunden
ist dass das wirklich der größte Anreiz
war für die Konzerne ihre Flotten
umzustellen das ist ein sehr wichtiges
Ding ist und die meisten sind schon auf
dem Weg dass die großen Autokonzerne
haben alle ein Ihr persönliches
Verbrenner aus schon beschlossen und
deswegen werden wir dann auch nachziehen
wie sehen sie sie sind ja nicht
glücklicher Menschen viel Kritik geübt
auch von der Mittelstand und Wirtschaft
und Union am Klima und
Wirtschaftsminister haben Beck sind sie
jetzt froh dass das mit dem Verbrenner
aus erstmal so nicht direkt umgesetzt
wird das kann ich ganz klar beantragen
Klimaschutz ist wichtig ohne Frage und
da verständigt man sich hin wieder auch
auf wichtige Beschlüsse aber man muss
schon immer auch ein bisschen schauen
was läuft gerade in der Wirklichkeit und
in der Welt ab und was läuft gerade in
diesem Land ab wir sind im Begriff eine
der wichtigsten Industrien die wir haben
ja
zu beenden und das wollen wir nicht ja
also es geht ja auch um Arbeitsplätze es
geht um Wertschöpfung in diesem Land und
es geht um eine Technologie für die wir
Deutschen wie vermutlich keine anderen
Nation steht und deswegen haben wir
schon immer gesagt Politik ist nicht der
Ideengeber für Wirtschaft das muss aus
den Unternehmen aus der Forschung kommen
die Frage was ist die beste Technologie
und was bewirkt sich am Ende am Markt
und diese technologieoffenheit die
vermisse ich in dieser Debatte quaschnik
ist das so dass wenn man jetzt sagt man
will keinen Verbrenner mehr haben das
Argument ist ja dass man dann sozusagen
die Möglichkeit mit e-fuse zu tanken
dass man die dann sozusagen mit beerdigt
wie wie sehen sie es aus ihrer
Wissenschaftler hat keine Zukunft mehr
also wir können natürlich ganz schön gut
Verbrenner bauen aber wir konnten noch
mal gut Pferdekutschen bauen ist halt
die Technik von von vorgestern und wir
können uns ja einfach mal überlegen
warum das so ist also das liegt einfach
an der Effizienz also verbrennerautos
haben ja nicht ohne Grund einen großen
Kühlergrill das liegt einfach daran dass
sie an Diesel oder ein Benzinmotor mit
dem Wirkungsgrad von 30 40 Prozent nur
herstellen können maximal das ist der
Nennbetrieb in der Praxis sogar noch ein
bisschen weniger der Rest ist Abwärme
das heißt ein Verbrennerauto und da
haben die Kolleginnen Kollegen der
kolbentechnik schon gute Jobs geleistet
also die sind schon gut die deutschen
Autos aber trotzdem haben wir einfach
keine Chance den Diesel Prozess soll den
otto-prozess mit 80 90 Prozent
Wirkungsgrad zu bauen das heißt der
Verbrenner ist ein Auto was extrem
ineffizient ist und nun überlegen wir
uns mal in 20 Jahren müssen wir ja weit
gegen klimaneutral sein das heißt also
der Verbrenner müsste dann mitfahren die
müssen wir aber aus Strom herstellen und
wenn ich jetzt einfach ein ineffizientes
Auto habe was dreimal so viel Energie
verbraucht wie ein Elektroauto und dann
noch die Herstellung der vorschalte
brauche ich vier fünf sechs sieben Mal
so viel Energie für den Betrieb eines
verbrennerautos wie für eine Elektroauto
es wird natürlich auch wenn ich den
gleichen Strom hernehme das Elektroauto
Faktor 457 billiger sein und deswegen
gibt es gar kein Markt mehr für
verbrennerautos und das wissen auch die
Hersteller gucken Sie doch einfach in
die Pläne mal ein der einzige der noch
überlegt nach dem Jahr 2035 neue
Verbrenner auf dem Markt zu bringen ist
Porsche die anderen und ein paar
ausländische Hersteller also die anderen
die haben sich davon schon verabschiedet
und deswegen ist es eine reine
Scheindiskussion den Verbrenner wird es
nicht mehr geben ja und warum denken sie
dann aber die FDP sagt wir wollen das
trotzdem so nicht machen
sehr starke Verbotsdiskussion ja wir
haben dann immer Boulevard-Medien die
kommen mal die wollen uns jetzt das Auto
verbieten also darum geht's ja gar nicht
ne also das heißt man muss jetzt ganz
klare Leitlinie setzen und muss ja auch
die Leute man hat ja auch ein bisschen
als Aufgabe der Politik die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zu schützen weil wenn ich
jetzt das falsche Auto kaufen die
wiederverkaufswerte werden auch
einbrechen irgendwann das heißt also
auch da müssen die Autokauf habe ich ein
Problem weil ich nur noch nicht die
Ladestation überall habe ich bräuchte ne
ich fahre selber seit drei Jahren
Elektroauto ich bin überall hingekommen
also natürlich muss man die Lade
Infrastruktur auch gleichzeitig mit nach
oben ziehen aber ich meine da geht es im
Wesentlichen Steckdosen bauen und daran
sollte es in Deutschland doch nicht
scheitern wir sehen Sie diese Diskussion
ist das jetzt also diese Blockadehaltung
die durch die FDP jetzt ausgelöst ist in
Brüssel ist das was so sie sagen ja dass
das ist sinnvoll auch im Sinne der
Industrie oder ist es eher man soll
warum ja eben sagte die Industrie
Autoindustrie hat sich schon total
darauf eingerichtet und die braucht vor
allen Dingen Plan aus Planungssicherheit
das stimmt sicherlich einerseits man
muss sich dann aber auch angucken warum
denn entsprechend wissen sich zu dieser
Blockade entschlossen hat es lag ein
ganz klarer Prüfauftrag vor der
Kommission die hat Herr Timmermanns
entsprechend bewusst oder unbewusst
ignoriert auf jeden Fall ist diese
Prüfungsauftrag nicht ausgeführt und das
ist jetzt der Grund warum dort
entsprechende Bremse reingebracht wird
Präsident zuständig für Umwelt
letztendlich sozusagen in diesem
Prüfungsaufträge müssen
da wurden jetzt gerade auch von Herrn
quaschning einige Dinge aus meiner Sicht
ein bisschen durcheinander geworfen
wenn wir über die reine Effizienz des
Verbrenners reden dann sind wir mit der
Verbrenner Effizienz über die letzten
Jahrzehnte glaube ich in einem sehr sehr
guten Leistungsspektrum
gelandet und
wo nehmen einzelne Stakeholder der
Diskussion
entsprechend den
die Weisheit her zu sagen dass und das
ist sowieso so und so weil das ist am
Ende dann entsprechend der günstigste
Weg den günstigsten Weg den zeigt am
Ende des Angebot am Markt auf und das
bedeutet dass man halt eben entsprechend
technologieoffen die entsprechend zur
Verfügung stehenden Technologien
gegeneinander antreten lassen soll und
dann kommen Effizienz Debatte die da
auch bedeutet wir wollen grünen Wasser
Strom Wasserstoff generieren um die
Zukunft zu machen zumindest für den
lastkraftverkehr werden wir an
Wasserstoff nicht vorbeikommen das wird
mit Strom oder rein Batterie getrieben
nicht funktionieren über die Strecke
dann frage ich mich warum sie diese
grünen Kraftstoffe dem Lkw-Verkehr
wegnehmen wollen den Flugverkehr wo sie
dringend gebraucht werden wo wir keine
Alternative haben und die sehr
effizienten Kraftstoffe also es ist
gesagt worden wir brauchen dann fünf Mal
mehr Strom für einen PKW dort einsetzen
das bedeutet doch dass es für den
Lastverkehr keine Umstellung geben kann
für eine Schiffsverkehr von Flugverkehr
wenn Sie die sehr kostbare Menge der
Grünen der ifuels die wir haben bei dem
PKWs einsetzen wollen so super
ineffizient ist also es ist auf jeden
Fall teurer also wenn ich fünf Mal mehr
Strom brauche das stimmen Sie mir zu ja
brauche ich ja nicht im Großraum rechnen
das ist auf jeden Fall teurer und das
benötigt sehr viel Energie wo sollen
nehmen also das ist mir einfach nicht
ganz genau bei der gesamten Lösung der
Debatte darum CO2 zu vermeiden das muss
eigentlich rüber oder das heißt also wir
wollen die Transition schaffen in eine
CO2 freie Welt
das bedeutet dass wir uns im Prinzip
überlegen müssen wie reduzieren wir CO2
und das bedeutet dass wir entsprechend
die imitierte Menge Preisen müssen und
das bedeutet dass wir letztendlich
eine Währung brauchen für CO2 Vermeidung
und dann ist es am Ende des Tages völlig
wurscht mit welcher mit welcher
Technologie das ganze umgesetzt wird es
wird automatisch über den Handel mit
CO2-Emissionen zu äh der günstigsten
Lösung für das entsprechende Problem
kommen
ein Problem dass wir sagen
also dass wir uns nicht dass wir nicht
irgendwann sagen wir müssen diesen Pfad
gehen wenn man dieses Klimaschutzgesetz
wirklich einhalten wollen muss geht es
dann nicht nur mit ja mit klaren
Richtlinien klaren verboten sind
entsprechend CO2 wollen wir entsprechend
imitieren in der Welt und das bedeutet
dass wir politisch demokratisch in
diesem Lande festlegen müssen
was wollen wir an imitieren Emission
zulassen damit entsprechen
fahre damit wir im 1,5 Grad Kanal
entsprechend bleiben können wie viel wie
viel Menge an CO2 können wir im Prinzip
sozusagen
zulassen zu imitieren diese Menge müssen
wir politisch festlegen und müssen Sie
entsprechend auch politisch vorgeben und
dann und dann
ergibt sich entsprechend über die
marktverwendung über die Emissionen ein
Preis wir haben wir haben einen Grund
beigetragen
das heißt also den Verkehrssektor muss
Klimaschutzgesetz die Klimaziel im
Verkehrsbereich werden nicht erreicht ja
dann sollten
doch das ist mir klar das ist ja höchste
Zeit dass entsprechende
sektorübergreifen der ETS ausgerollt
wird damit entsprechend die CO2
Emissionen ein Preis bekommen und zwar
ein Preis in der Markt festsetzt und die
nicht irgendwer festsetzt und sagt das
ist billig oder das ist teuer
ist entscheidet doch am Ende der Kunde
also der Preis hilft bei einigen
Sektoren also
CO2-Zertifikate helfen im
Industriebereich das im Erfolg voll der
Chor im Automobilbereich hilft er nicht
das kann man mal ganz einfach in der
corona-krise gesehen wir waren also in
der corona-krise beim Spritpreis von 1
Euro der ist ja dann durch den Krieg
nach oben geschossen auf 1802 Euro
und das sind ungefähr 300 € die Tonne
CO2 wenn wir das preisgetrieben hätten
machen wollen werden mal gesehen was wir
da für eine Auswirkung auf dem Markt
gehabt haben fast keine das heißt die
Anzahl der Fahrstrecken sind ähnlich
geblieben bisschen gesunken die Leute
sind ein bisschen langsamer gefahren
aber also alleine also auch 300 € die
Tonne CO2 haben im Verkehrsbereich kaum
eine Auswirkung das heißt es gibt
Sektoren wo sie mit dem Preis was machen
können das heißt das CO2 Preis
Instrument ist gut aber nicht überall
und im Verkehrsbereich sehen wir dass
die Menschen halt einfach auch nicht
einfach nur durch den Preis reagieren
sondern einfach emotional das heißt das
Auto wird nach der Farbe gekauft immer
und nicht nach dem Preis oder nach dem
Hersteller und deswegen brauchen wir
hier ganz klare Signale dass einfach
viel Entwicklungen vermieden werden und
wir können einfach einfach mal diesen
effizienzgedanken zu Ende denken das ist
glaube ich eigentlich viel nicht klar
wenn wir jetzt die ganze deutsche
automobilflotte einfach heute mal
umstellen wollten auf e-fuels dann
brauchen wir fast doppelt so viel Strom
wie wir derzeit heute insgesamt in
Deutschland produzieren um diese e-fuels
herzustellen dann kann man sagen okay
das werden wir nicht in Deutschland
machen das machen wir in Chile das hat
jetzt ja Lindner gesagt ich habe mal
ausgerechnet dann brauchen wir sieben
Mal so viel Strom wie Chile heute
insgesamt produziert nur für den
deutschen Straßenverkehr wie soll das
funktionieren in 15 Jahren diese Mengen
an Strom werden wir nicht bereitstellen
können die e-fluss werden knapp sein und
dann müssen sie da einsetzen wo wir sie
brauchen und das ist der Flugverkehr zum
Beispiel sonst können sie nämlich nicht
mehr fliegen und das ist glaube ich viel
schlimmer was würden Sie denn sagen wie
wenn man sagt die der Verkehrsbereich
muss sein Anteil dazu beitragen wie
würden sie es denn sagen wie kann man
das erreichen ich finde das ja
bemerkenswert dass die Erzeugung von
Strom und die Menge von Strom jetzt auf
einmal ein Problem sein soll wir wissen
doch dass wir CO2 neutral auf Strom
produzieren können und das was politisch
an Zielen ausgereicht wird das alles
elektrifiziert wird der Verkehr die
Versorgung zu Hause da gab es
offensichtlich diese Probleme nie bei
der Frage wo kriegen wir den ganzen
Strom her ich meine ich stelle mir die
Frage schon seit längerem wie soll der
Strom eigentlich dann in die ganzen
Ladestationen kommen und nach Hause in
die Häuser das war bisher kein Problem
hier verwenden Sie es als Gegenargument
gegen efeues und das ist eben nicht
sauber ja ein Fünftel des Stroms für die
Elektromobilität sie wollen ja fünf Mal
so viel Strom noch verbrauchen dann
müssen wir erstmal mehr Herrn Söder
reden dass ein paar Windräder hinstellt
was ist denn das Problem sehr
durchsichtige Diskussion es geht einfach
mal wieder darum Transformation zu
verhindern Klimaschutz zu verhindern und
nicht darüber zu reden dass wir eine
Verkehrswende brauchen da geht's
übrigens auch in die Menge der PKWs wir
haben aktuell
PKWs als Menschen also auf jede zweite
Person sollte ein Kreis kommt ein Pkw in
Deutschland
sehr große PKW ähm es geht darum dass
Menschen umsteigen können es gibt auch
13 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland die
kein Auto haben das ist ihnen ja egal
die Leute lassen sie hinten runterfallen
ländlicher Raum da muss ich hier das
Auto ländlichen Raum hinten rüber und
dann möchte ich das möchte ich das
einfach zögerungsargument für die
Verkehrswende das ist das für diese
Diskussion hier abbilden und wir werden
nicht ein bisschen oder sie wie auch
immer wird nicht damit durchkommen dass
die Verkehrswende mit efuels
abgefrüchtet ist das wird nicht
passieren und zu Industrie möchte ich
auch noch ein Wort sagen weil sie die
deutsche Industrie im Stich lassen ich
komme aus einer auto-zuliefer-region und
ich weiß was passiert wenn die
Autoindustrie sich seit Jahrzehnten
nicht darauf einstellt dass das
Verbrenner auskommt dass man in dieser
Elektromobilen Wertschöpfungskette
teilhaben kann das ist gerade für die
Kleinen Zulieferer kann es das auch sein
weil wir jetzt als Deutschland zu spät
dran sind weil viele Jahre auch Frau
Merkel ja versucht diese Privilegien in
Brüssel zu schützen mit dem Endeffekt
mit dem Endergebnis dass die deutsche
Autoindustrie jetzt die Elektrode
Wertschöpfungskette angeht fast
abgehängt ist ja können es noch schaffen
aber nicht wenn sie jetzt weiter
verhindern und dann habe ich Angst um
Tausende von Industriearbeitsplätzen in
meinem Wahlkreis und nicht nur in meinem
Wald
viele in der Autoindustrie haben sich ja
wirklich umgestellt auf E-Autos und
wissen dass sie das dass der verbrennen
dass das Verbrenner aus ja irgendwie
kommt dann ist das eine wichtigste nicht
dass man da eine ja einen
Planungssicherheit hat dass man klar
weiß wo es lang geht also persönlich
bedauere ich das schon dass man
sozusagen diesen aus meiner Sicht doch
einseitigem Weg der E-Mobilität in der
Vergangenheit gegangen ist ich hätte mir
schon gewünscht dass auch von Seiten der
Automobilindustrie dort etwas mehr
Gegenwind gekommen wäre in der
Vergangenheit wir haben uns politisch
dann sehr sehr stark für
technologieoffenheit eingesetzt die dann
am Ende auch zumindestens in unserer
Außenwirkung dann auch kam und ich finde
auch jetzt muss die Autoindustrie dort
als als Sprachrohr ja und als Ideengeber
vorangehen und eben nicht nur mit einer
einseitigen Technologie aber wenn ich
das noch mal ganz kurz sagen darf weil
das ist jetzt gerade sehr wichtig sie
haben gesagt es geht auch um die Anzahl
der Fahrzeuge auf der Straße es geht
damit Ihnen auch um Einschränkung der
Mobilität das soll an der Stelle mal
ganz klar festgehalten werden und das
ist etwas was wir nicht unterstützen
können wir wollen Individualität im
Verkehr ich möchte entscheiden wann ich
wohin fahre ja und es den Leuten nicht
vorschreiben und jeder soll sich in
diesem Land ein Auto leisten können ein
Auto kaufen das ist ihre Losung die sie
ausgeben
vielleicht auch Leute mit dem ÖPNV
Fahrenheit die haben sie doch schon gar
nicht mehr woher wollen Sie das denn her
nehmen alles gleichzeitig zu fördern es
funktioniert nicht das haben die letzten
Jahre gesehen die Straße also wenn man
sagt der Verkehr ist für uns wichtig
dann könnte man durchaus einen anderen
Politikfeldern ein bisschen einsparen
die Möglichkeit gibt es durchaus darüber
reden
kommen ja aus dem ländlichen Wahlkreis
da braucht man sicherlich ein Auto das
ist ja was anderes wie in Berlin
Leuten vorzuschreiben der sich ein Auto
zu kaufen hat das sollen sie selbst
entscheiden dann dafür gehen sie
arbeiten dafür bekommen sie jeden Monat
ihr Entgelt aufs Konto überwiesen das
schreibe ich den Leut
aber was wie erreichen wir dann aber die
Ziele des Klimaschutzgesetz den die
Union ja auch zugestimmt hat indem wir
indem wir einfach den Unternehmen und
auch den Forschenden Instituten die
Möglichkeiten geben gute Dinge zu
erforschen und zu produzieren und
marktfähig zu machen und nicht durch
politisch einseitige Diskussionen auf
nur einen Lösungsweg verengeln
technologieoffenheit ist ja das was
jetzt immer fällt ist man hat das Gefühl
das ist jetzt die Diskussion
technologieoffenheit gegen Verbote auch
auf anderen Ebenen also ich hätte noch
einen Vorschlag genau also wir reißen ja
die Ziele in im Verkehr beim CO2 und die
werden wir jedes Jahr noch stärker
Reisen das zeigt eigentlich die
Projektion also haben keine Chance jetzt
sind sie ja ein Verfechter von den
euholster machen Sie doch eine
weibischungspflicht für uns ab 2025 dass
wir mit den efuels die Emissionen auf
den Wert runter drücken wie wir sie
brauchen das wäre doch mal eine Sache
dann können sie ja zeigen dass die 15
tolle Sache sind und wir das
entsprechend auch hier realisieren
können was wäre es damit
das können sie gerne
verboten Beimischungspflicht ab 2025 5%
e-fuels für die Flotte dann haben wir
die CO2 Werte wieder erreicht
sozusagen
zehn Jahren und ich glaube die Leute
sind einfach schlauer geworden ja sie
wissen dass sie mehr Optionen brauchen
und dass sie die Wahlmöglichkeiten
brauchen und die haben wir zurzeit nicht
gerade im Bereich Verkehr ich habe auch
leider nicht die Chance aktuell oder
Wasserstoff in der Tankstelle zu tanken
das Krankenschwester mit einem Auto ich
leider auch nicht der Punkt
Möglichkeiten
also Ehrlichkeit
die Rede wir haben 42 %
entsprechend
mit erneuerbaren Energien versorgt ist
ebenso stimmen Sie mir dazu
okay wir haben irgendwas zwischen 45 und
50 erreicht das haben wir mit 480
Milliarden Euro verkauft
so Lasten derjenigen die Strom
entsprechend beziehen im gleichen
Zeitraum 1,6 Millionen fossile
Energieträger importiert
dass sie
Erneuerbaren 500
Milliarden Terawattstunden plus eine
Apple Stückchen dazu kommt im Prinzip
600 Milliarden Terawattstunden Energie
im verkehrsegment und dann kommen da
knapp 1.300 Milliarden
Kilowattstunden sind 1300
Terawattstunden Milliarden
Kilowattstunden
der Wärmemarkt dazu und das behauptet
entsprechend ihre Partei das wird alles
mit Strom in Zukunft gelöst
machen
gehen und dann müssen wir die Frage
danach nachher Stellen entsprechen wie
wollen wir das ganze bezahlen wie wollen
wir diese transition finanzieren und
zwar ohne dass entsprechend in der
deutschen Wirtschaft eine die
Industrialisierung stattfindet sich hier
der Probleme haben in ihrem Wahlkreis zu
viele Arbeitslosen
automobilzuliefernindustrie zu haben
weil eins ist auch gucken sich die
Firma Bosch an ja sie haben entsprechend
so ein Berg nehmen wie Feuerbach da
haben sie entsprechend 11 oder 13000
Mitarbeiter wenn Sie das Ding komplett
für die Elektro Mobilität machen da
haben sie noch Arbeitsplätze für 3000
Mitarbeiter was passiert
hat gesagt er will vier bis fünf
Windräder am Tag bauen
einfach nur dokumentieren ich will damit
einfach nur dokumentieren dass diese
Diskussion nicht von Politikern gelöst
werden kann sondern die kann nur von der
Wirtschaft gelöst werden
es ist schade wenn es ein Abgeordnete
sagt weil ihr Job ist es eigentlich
Gesetze zu machen also wie heißt mein
Job als Abgeordnete verstehe
nicht über ich werde ja nicht
übergriffig entscheidet so wie sie das
tun ja natürlich die Menschen wollen
reden mit der Zivilgesellschaft und der
Wirtschaft aber ich verstehe meinen Job
so dass ich dann auch Entscheidungen
treffe als repräsentan der BürgerInnen
Bundestag aber sie sind
verloren bei Ihnen sagen
Planungssicherheit braucht niemand wir
sagen der Wirtschaft nicht wie ist die
nächsten Jahre weiter geht
es gab keine Planungssicherheit auch in
der Erneuerbaren energienbranche nicht
aber das ist vielleicht ein weiteres
System
wie sehr wie schätzen Sie die Wirtschaft
ein also wenn man sagt wir haben alle
auch die Union hat diesen Klimaschutz
zugestimmt das muss ja irgendwie
umgesetzt werden auch mit Hilfe der
Wirtschaft sonst geht's ja nicht also
wie ich und bei der Automobilindustrie
die stellt sich ein dass der Verbrenner
weil das den Wald nicht mehr gibt wann
auch immer also wie schätzen Sie das ein
wie sehr
also welchen Einfluss hat es auf die
Industrie hier in Deutschland nur was
die Industrie braucht es halt
Planungssicherheit also das heißt das
größte Gift für eine Industrie ist keine
Planungssicherheit zu haben und wenn man
versucht zwei Pferde gleichzeitig zu
reiten dann dann hat man halt einfach
auf eins von beiden auf das falsche
gesetzt und das werden wir uns in
Deutschland nicht leisten können weil
der Druck aus dem Ausland ist halt
einfach auch enorm wir haben das erstmal
bei der Photovoltaik gesehen in
Deutschland war mal führend bei der
Photovoltaik vor 10 Jahren haben wir
noch irgendwie in Europa 30 40% der
Solarmodule hergestellt heute kommen von
den Kernkomponenten bei Solarmodul 99%
aus China und damals hatten wir nie
gedacht dass sie uns das andere erringen
können ähnlich sieht es bei der
Automobilindustrie aus weil wir wissen
die Elektroautos wir sehen da ein
Preisverfall bei Batterien der enorm ist
das heißt also in wenigen Jahren wird
das Elektroauto deutlich preisgünstiger
auf dem Markt sein als der Verbrenner
das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit und dann
werden natürlich auch die chinesischen
Autos auf den Markt drängen wir haben ja
schon mal versucht das war die war nicht
gut die Autos die hatten irgendwie im
Crash Test durchgefallen es können die
jetzt aber mittlerweile und wir werden
chinesische Autos mit 5 600 Kilometern
Reichweite für 10 15.000 Euro sehen hier
in Deutschland angeboten werden und dann
möchte ich sehen ob die Leute dann
einfach sagen oh das deutsche hat aber
ein schöneres Design oder für made in
Germany dann wird der Preis entscheiden
und dann werden wir die deutsche
Automobilindustrie gegen die Wand fahren
wenn wir ihr nicht klare
Rahmenbedingungen geben und sie
unterstützen gegen diesen
internationalen Druck zu machen weil die
Chinesen haben uns einen anderen
Bereichen schon richtig Druck gemacht
und die werden das auch im
Automobilbereich da sind die gerade dran
sie sind beim Elektromobilität wenn sie
irgendwie in China unterwegs sind und
einfach mal schauen was da in der
Elektromobilität los sind da sind wir
Entwicklungsland und wenn wir nicht
aufholen dann haben wir hier wirklich
das Risiko dass wir in Deutschland in
den Anschluss verlieren weil auf der
Welt werden sie in 20 Jahren keine
Verbrennungsmotoren mehr verkaufen sie
können irgendwie alte Schrottautos nach
Afrika liefern aber keine neuen
Verbrenner mehr absetzen können und
deswegen setzen wir dann aufs falsche
für überzeugt vorstellen können
überhaupt nicht weil am Ende haben wir
auch unseren Know-how ja und man muss es
schlichtweg weiterentwickeln und auch
ein verbrenner motor kann
weiterentwickelt werden indem der
Kraftstoff weiterentwickelt wird und
dass das keine Zukunft hat das kann ich
so nicht kann ich so nicht
unterschreiben und am Ende entscheidet
es der Markt noch einmal ich verstehe
mein Mandat nicht so als dass ich den
Leuten vorschreibe und den Unternehmen
vorschreibe wie sie zu leben und wie sie
zu arbeiten haben und indem ich gute
Ideen im Keim ersticke das tue ich nicht
aber irgendwie müssen da diese
Klimaziele auf die wir uns vereinigt
haben erreichen darüber reden ob die
Klimaziele realistisch sind ja auch das
gehört zur Wahrheit dazu ja kann man
sagen Klimaschutz kann man doch so sagen
ich kann doch am Ende nur auch eine
Klimaschutz
umsetzen die auch umsetzbar ist in einem
Land das bringt es mir denn wenn ich die
Hälfte Sommer können Sie doch auf mit
dem Arzt was hat denn das damit zu tun
ich bitte Sie also das ist ja
unglaublich so ich kann doch noch mal
ich kann doch am Ende mir ehrgeizige
Ziele setzen absoluter gar keine Frage
aber wenn ich meine Wirtschaft damit
abwürge wenn ich die Hälfte der
Arbeitsplätze damit vernichte in einer
Branche dann ist das kein gutes Ziel
dass ich mir da gesetzt habe das gehört
zu weit dazu wir müssen immer auf dem
Boden der Realität bleiben bei allen
Zielen die wir uns setzen ein anderes
Ziel um mal von dem Verbrenner und den
Autos wegzukommen zu dem zweiten Thema
nämlich bei dem Thema Heizung ist es
genau dieses dass es jetzt noch eher
geiziger vorangetrieben werden soll das
nämlich nicht erst seit 25 neue
Heizungen eben nicht mehr aus Gas oder
Ölheizung sein sollen sondern dann auch
ab 24 schon er hat eine wie realistisch
ist das denn ihrer Meinung ist das ein
richtiger Ansatz dass man sagt ja wir
müssen damit so umgehen wir müssen das
eben ändern das System wenn man dort die
Geschwindigkeit entsprechend aufnehmen
will so wie sie gefordert ist dann
bedeutet das dass wir uns darüber im
Klaren sein müssen weil eben 500.000
Fachkräfte zusätzlich brauchen um den
ganzen Kram einzubauen
ja die braucht man im Allgemeinen die
braucht man im allgemeinen drei bis vier
Jahre zum Ausbilden in der Zeit kann
dann die Industrie zusehen dass sie
entsprechend die Stückzahlen skaliert
etc pp das halte ich in der
Geschwindigkeit wie es gefordert ist für
sehr ambitioniert der Punkt ist der ich
ich werde mich äh Frau war nämlich
während ich da wirklich ein Stück weit
gegen so wie sie im Prinzip
da schon einer polemikgrenzen in die
Diskussion 1 sein das ist immer der Burg
gezeigt Zeigefinger immer der Vogel
Zeigefinger sie haben gerade
wortwörtlich gesagt ähm Frau Schimke
sind die nachfolgenden Generationen egal
das finde ich eine unverschämte
Unterstellungen
direkt sagen das macht mich wütend ähm
weil glauben sie wenn ich in unserem
Verband
in der energiepolitischen Kommission und
außerhalb mit Unternehmern diskutiere da
ist die Frage ob Energiewende zu tätigen
ist zu stemmen es ist keine Frage mehr
sondern das ist ein da ist ein Haken
dran da ist ein gesellschaftlicher
konsen nimmt das bei den Grünen bitte
war wir sind da nicht die Feinde sondern
wir sind die dies machen müssen
ich meine wir haben ein paar dieser
Klimaschutzabkommen das irgendwie uns
Vorgaben macht und wir haben ein
Verfassungsgericht Urteil das einfach
mal zu sagen wir reden jetzt über die
Klimaschutzziele und weichen die ein
bisschen auf das ist irgendwie alleine
durch das Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts
überhaupt gar nicht möglich weil das
gesagt hat also im Prinzip werden wir
sogar eine Urteile sehen die sagen dass
wir schneller Klimaschutz machen müssen
weil die ganzen Klima
Forschungsergebnisse zeigen eigentlich
dass die Klima Neutralität 2045 uns in
eine Welt führen wird die zwei Grad oder
mehr hat und ich möchte einfach mal ein
Zitat aus dem Weltklima Bericht dem
letzten geben und ähm da steht drin bei
also bei Emissionen die weiter in der
Höhe sind die wir haben werden wir im
Jahr 2300 ein Meeresspiegelanstieg von
über 15 Metern nicht ausschließen können
das heißt also wir werden dann
irgendwann Küstenstädte wie Hamburg oder
Bremen versenken ja und sie reden dann
entsprechend hier über über Wirtschaft
die wird es dann in dem Moment nicht
mehr geben wenn wir das nicht in den
Griff kriegen und deswegen müssen wir
wirklich die Klimaschutzziele einhalten
und es gibt ein
verfassungsgerichtsurteilen ich finde
schade dass eine christliche eine
Vertretung eine christliche
demokratischen Vision sagt irgendwie was
das Verfassungsgericht gesagt hat egal
wir können das Klimaschutz sie haben
gesagt wir müssen die Klimaschutzziele
der müssen darüber reden haben sie
gesagt ob wir das so ambitioniert machen
können das heißt die stellen das
Klimaschutz das Urteil vom
Verfassungsgericht damit in Frage das
ist das was man angekommen ich würde
gerne mal konkret bei den Heizungen
bleiben ist es warum heißt das jetzt
warum muss es unbedingt jetzt ein Jahr
vorgezogen wird obwohl die Koalition
sich erst etwas anderes geeinigt hatte
und wenn man genau das sieht was er was
er na ja sagt also jeder zweite Haushalt
hat mit Gas in Deutschland und die
Wärmepumpen auf die wartet man ein
halbes Jahr bis anderthalb Jahre es gibt
dafür die Fachkräfte nicht also machen
wir uns da nicht was vor naja also
müssen erstmal das Klimaschutzzielen uns
anschauen 2023 haben wir heute und eine
Heizung lebt halt bis zu 30 Jahren das
heißt also die Heizung die wir heute
einbauen sind im Jahr 2053 noch in den
Häusern drin wir dürfen aber 2045 keine
Öl und Gasheizung mehr betreiben laut
Klimaschutzgesetz hat Verfassungsgericht
Urteil das heißt wir müssen uns dann
überlegen wie kriege ich die wieder raus
enteig dann die Leute natürlich eine
abfrageprämie irgendwie versuchen wir
die Netze auf Wasserstoff umzustellen da
kann ich mit ihnen technisch lange
diskutieren warum das nicht klappen wird
das heißt sie haben ja gar keinen Plan
darüber wie wir dann also die Heizung
die wir heute schon einbauen ja die
klimaneutral bekommen das geht schon
nicht und wenn man dann noch ein paar
Jahre zu warten wird das Problem ja umso
größer und deswegen müssen wir so
schnell wie möglich den Einbau von Gas
und Ölheizung irgendwie unterbinden und
wenn wir auf andere Länder gucken
dänemark hat das zum Beispiel 2013 schon
beschlossen das funktioniert das einfach
und wir in Deutschland sagen hier geht
das einfach nicht die deutsche
Wirtschaft geht runter als gucken Sie
mal nach Dänemark die sind auch nicht
alle Arbeitslosen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
machen das ja schon also im Vergleich zu
zum Vorjahr gab es jetzt im letzten
Zuwachs von 53 % bei den Wärmepumpen
also kann ich nicht auch ein Stück
darauf vertrauen dass die Menschen das
ja tun werden genau wie sie Photovoltaik
auf ihre Dächer machen genauso wie sie
bestimmte andere Sachen warum musste so
mit dem
Brechstange jetzt unbedingt ganz schnell
umgesetzt werden ich würde gerne noch
einen Schritt zurückgehen weil einen ein
gutes hat er die Transparenz von was ich
schwierig finde sind immer diese Akteure
die sagen wir haben Klimaziele müssen
die einhalten dann jede konkrete
Maßnahme
darum geht es hier zwei einzusparen aber
bekämpfen sie sagen wenigstens ehrlich
das in die Klimaziel nichts wert sind
dann kann sich können sich alle
zuschauen zuschauen auch ein Urteil
bilden aber jetzt zum Thema Gebäude
ich glaube es geht darum auch hier eine
neue Technologie zu etablieren und viele
Installateure kennt das Thema Wärmepumpe
noch nicht viele MieterInnen Miete
Eigentümern Eigentümer kennen bisher vor
allem Öl und Gasheizung das weiß man da
ist die Ölheizung ist im Keller da hat
man die und die Wartungen es geht ja
ganz viele ihre Ölheizung ausgetauscht
gegen eine Gasheizung
Zukunft
und wir haben gesehen dass leider ich
freue mich über den Hochlauf der
Wärmepumpe im letzten Jahr da haben wir
übrigens auch gezeigt 50.000 auf 150.000
Wärmepumpen in einem Jahr in der Lage
sind deswegen würde ich ehrlich gesagt
das auch nicht schlecht reden wollen
unsere Industrie sondern wir machen sehr
viel aber es wurden leider auch 600.000
Gasheizungen eingebaut weil wir können
nur spekulieren man vielleicht denkt
gaspreisbremse oder wie werden so viele
andere Gasquellen haben dann passt es
schon das Problem ist nur wenn die
Heizung einmal eingebaut ist ne ist die
für 10 20 Jahre je nach Modell
Gasheizung 15 Jahre eingebaut und dann
kann dieses Haus logischerweise auch
nicht mehr klimaneutral beheizt werden
und deswegen haben wir eben nicht mehr
endlos viel Zeit es geht darum jetzt den
Anreiz zu setzen und auch hier wieder
Planungssicherheit zu geben den
Installateuren der Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern das ist hier der Weg du kannst
dich darauf einstellen wir haben sehr
sehr lange Übergangsfristen von vielen
Jahren wir werden Härtefälle haben und
so weiter und so fort es geht nur darum
wenn jemand neu Heizung kaufen muss und
wenn die Heizung kaputt ist ja also wenn
ich eine funktionierende Heizung habe
dann wird die selbstverständlich
weiterlaufen mit dem neuen Gesetz also
ist es mal wieder ich sag mal
Unterstützung der Bürger
Planungssicherheit so das ist das wo die
politische Reise hingeht und eben auch
für die Fachkräfte in die Richtung
müssen wir uns weiterentwickeln wir
brauchen jetzt eben auch mehr Leute
Wärmepumpen einbauen
eine klare Ansage dass man sagt wenn ich
Installateur bin weiß ich genau worauf
ich mich jetzt einstellen muss ist das
nicht genau das was dann was man braucht
sozusagen
Installateur unterhalten und ich hatte
entsprechend nicht den Eindruck dass äh
denen nicht völlig klar ist dass ähm Gas
und Öl
auslaufmodelle sind und jede jede neue
Heizung die dort entsprechend eingebaut
wird
ist eine Wärmepumpe auch da muss man
entsprechend ein Stück weit wieder
genauer hinschauen wir haben jede Menge
Bestands Immobilien ich glaube
hundertprozentig genau auf jeden Fall
eine sehr immens hohe Bestandsimmobilien
Anzahl die energetisch nicht auf dem
Level sind das halt eben die Wärmepumpe
ein tolles
beheizungsinstrumente ist sondern dann
wird entsprechend bei den derzeitigen
Stromkosten über die wir aktuell mit den
aktuell konfrontiert sind das eine
ziemlich teure Veranstaltung und zwar
dann halt eben unter Umständen genau
gerade für diejenigen die sich nicht so
gut leisten können also und ähm
auch da komme ich wieder zu dem Punkt
hin wenn dann entsprechend der Gebäude
Sektor mit im ETS wäre dann ist das und
da haben wir wirklich genügend Zeit ein
wunderbarer Pfad um
entsprechende Heizung 20 Jahre eingebaut
sind baut sich halt einer die falsche
Heizung heute ein er musste sie in 15
Jahren halt entsprechend wieder ausbauen
Entscheidung getroffen hat
in 15 Jahren 20 Jahren ist es nicht zu
spät wenn wir in 15 20 Jahren erstes
Cousine Heizungen ausbauen ist es zu
verstehen
in 15 Jahren werden sie dann
verpflichtet also liebe Leute baut euch
jetzt noch Gas in Ölheizung rein nein
so teuer zu betreiben sein dass sie sich
überhaupt nicht lohnt ja das haben wir
jetzt gesehen das gaspreisbremse nicht
also insofern ähm
gerade ein paar Sachen die ich sage
unfair durcheinander ich habe gesagt
wenn der Gebäude Sektor im ETS
entsprechend verankert ist also sprich
die co2-preisung über die Emission
stattfindet und zwar entsprechend
aktuell
ganz toll nur das Problem meiner
Angelegenheit sie werden entsprechend
die co2-lösung entsprechend nicht in
Deutschland generieren sondern da müsste
schon weltweit umsetzen weil das sind
weltweites Problem ja die Klimakrise
werden wir nicht in Deutschland dadurch
lösen dass wir entsprechend Deutschland
die industrialisieren so wie sie das
gerade betreiben
es heißt wir brauchen jetzt ganz viele
Wärmepumpen zum Beispiel das ist doch
dann eigentlich ein Handschuh für die
Wirtschaft und für die Gesellschaft
schon aber wir müssen ja letztendlich
sozusagen wir müssen dann aber auch mal
die die
gesamtwirtschaftlichen
wertschöpfungselemente entsprechen uns
angucken und da ist letztendlich
sozusagen sicherlich der heizungssektor
mit Wärmepumpen nicht zwingen zu
vergleichen mit Montanindustrie oder mit
einer Automobilindustrie
gefunden nicht laufen die Leute wollen
das ja und die möchten sich das auch
einbinden einbauen aber wenn dann der
Wirtschaftsminister die Förderung im
Neubau dafür einfach mal abschafft
braucht man sich nicht wundern wenn dann
die Investitionsfreudigkeit auch ein
Stück weit zurück in wenn ich etwas
politisch will dann muss ich es auch
unterstützen ja und das gilt gerade auch
für den Gebäudesektor haben sie
vertrauen dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger das von sich aus all diese
definierten natürlich definitiv klar die
gucken oder muss es da mehr Subventionen
mehr untersuchen also die Menschen haben
eine Sensibilität die gucken ganz genau
wie kann ich meine späteren Nebenkosten
im Griff behalten die gucken sich den
Markt an und die versuchen wirklich mit
ihrer Kenntnis die sie haben eine gute
Entscheidung für Ihre Immobilie für ihre
Neubau zu treffen so und da finde ich
muss Staat soll Staat auch flankieren
mit finanziellen Anreizen so wird das
funktioniert
wieder neu fördern
jahrelang natürlich auch eine
Entscheidung treffen das ist eine
Entscheidung für die Wärme ich wofür ich
sehr bin was ich sehr unterstütze doch
nicht das geht warum die Gasheizung
persönlich nicht und wir müssen die
ausbauen die Gasheizung
werden da darum geht es aber deswegen
kann ich doch etwas Gutes finanziell
fördern ich kann noch das eine tun und
das andere muss ich doch deshalb nicht
unterlassen wir haben unendlich viel
Geld oder wie also gleichzeitig fossiles
fördern Steuerung von dann haben wir
keine Transformation fördern
ich weiß nicht wie es bei ihnen ist also
bei uns ist es so der Bundeshaushalt der
kann jeder Euro nur einmal ausgeben
immer ihr Totschlagargument ne wenn man
eine gute Idee bringt sagen Sie es ist
kein Geld da ich es ist es schon Geld da
also schon Geld an die Frage ist wofür
gibt man es aus und wofür entscheidet
erneuerbare Zukunft
gehen relativ klar vor allem wie
effizient gibt man das auch
gefördert hat widerspricht völlig zielt
korrigieren besser machen nicht
machen machen wir es bitte schön max
und zwar ökonomisch maximal effizient
das heißt nicht entsprechend mit der
Gießkanne im Prinzip über jede
über jede Heizung eine Förderung
ausrollen und dann auch die Forderung
aufsetzen um das zu beschleunigen wird
wird die Summe noch erhöht sondern sie
müssen im Prinzip das System drumherum
ich komme immer wieder zurück auf diese
Thematik wenn sie entsprechend nationale
Instrumente in den Vordergrund schieben
dann werden sie global das Problem nicht
lösen wir müssen Minimum minimal auf
europäischer Lösung da haben wir einen
wahnsinnig gut funktionierendes das
weltweit beste Instrument was es
entsprechend gibt in der Reduktion von
CO2 nennt sich ETS ja das
emissionshandelsystem und in diesem
emissionshandelsystem müssen alle
Sektoren rein und dann werden sie denn
dann können sie gar nicht so schnell zu
gucken wie sie entsprechend Klimaziele
erreichen
finanzieren
heute in dem Vertrauen dass alles so
bleibt
10 bis 15 Jahren wird es dann so teuer
dass es nicht mehr leisten können und
Sie müssen dir vorzeitig wieder
rausreißen das ist ja auch nicht
sonderlich effizient das ist ja genau
entsprechend dem Bürger pass mal auf du
bist doof ich weiß das alles viel besser
und deswegen machst du das jetzt so und
so und deswegen machen Gesetz dran das
ist grüne Politik aktuell so wie ich sie
wahrnehmen entschuldigung
das ist das was sicher hier vorschlagen
wie soll nichts machen wie sollen die
Hände in schoßlegen
Sicherheit gegeben
zu machen grüne Politik ist dann ja
damit kann ich mich sehr gut infizieren
das Problem meine Angelegenheit ist ich
komme noch mal wieder drauf zurück diese
Geburtstag ist sowas vom alter Hut aber
überhaupt keine innerliche Argumente
sorry noch mal das wird nicht mehr
ziehen wir sind im Jahr 2023 würden Sie
sagen man muss gar nichts verbieten es
sollte keine Regelungen geben für also
das ist natürlich muss es Regelungen
geben
dafür da um den Level Pläne viel zu
generieren ja so das heißt also im
Prinzip die Rahmenregelung drum rum
die setzen
20 verschiedene Gesetze
ja
bitte mal grundkursordnungspolitik ja
dass das eine und das andere ist ich
verwahre mich wirklich immer gegen diese
Zwischentöne
also das ist eine diskussionshaltung von
ihnen die finde ich wirklich sie sind
ein Problemlösen Problemlösen im
Gespräch gar nicht interessiert
sie wollen den Konflikt und sie sagen
die andere Seite ist blöd ich habe keine
Lösung von ihnen gehört außer dass wir
nichts machen sollen ich habe gerade
glaube ich
fünf oder sechs Mal der Staat gibt den
Menschen einen Rahmen aber innerhalb
dieses Rahmens lässt er ihnen die
Möglichkeit und auch den Unternehmen der
Wirtschaft den Markt am Ende das
durchzusetzen was gut ist und
der muss ja dann auch das halten wenn
man es konkret macht hieß ja dann der
Rahmen auch ab dann und dann keiner Gas
und Ölheizung mehr oder ab dann und dann
keine Verbrenner mehr sind sondern das
langfristig ähm organisiert kommuniziert
und gestaltet dann ist das durchaus
eingegangen wahrer weg aber das ist auch
ein Verbot
das selbstverständlich Spiel hatten ja
das man muss man Zeitperspektiven man
zeigt Linien auf aber Sie müssen sich in
einem realistischen Rahmen befinden es
ist ja wie bei der Kohle da streiten wir
ja auch darum bleibt es bei 38 wie
versprochen oder reden wir nur noch über
30 und was passiert danach ne wo kriegen
wir danach unseren Strom her also ich
finde es war ja die CDU-Regierung die
den Atomausstieg früher wollte alles gut
mach mein Haken dran Thema ist geklärt
wir haben dazu eine Haltung die ist
relativ klar aber ich finde ich muss
mich als Politik schon regelmäßig auch
korrigieren und kontrollieren und gucken
ist das richtig und gut was ich mache
und ich muss vor allen Dingen meine
Entscheidung vom Ende her denken auch
vom zeitlichen Ende ich würde gerne noch
mal gucken ob man hier irgendwie noch
zusammen kommt weil wenn das die Art ist
wie man darüber redet und wer aber
eigentlich uns alle einig sind das wäre
ja die klimaschutzgesetze gerne
einhalten wollen und das Pariser
Klimaziel wo sehen Sie denn da Ansätze
auch wenn sie jetzt so auch ganz konkret
FDP und Grüne da betrachten die ja genau
da in diesem Spannungsfeld sich mehr ich
meine das Klimaschutzgesetz ist
eigentlich relativ klar wir haben es
Klimaziele die sind jedes Jahr
einzuhalten und wenn die nicht
eingehalten werden muss ein
Sofortprogramm vorgelegt werden das
nachgeschärft wird das ist im nächsten
Jahr klappt und wenn es dann nicht
klappt dann muss man entsprechend die
Maßnahmen machen es klappt momentan
nicht weder im Verkehr noch noch
Wohnungsbereich da sieht es nicht ganz
so schlimm aus aber da laufen die Zahlen
auch auseinander und dann muss man
entsprechend reagieren und das was jetzt
an Vorschlägen auf den Tisch liegen aus
wissenschaftlicher Sicht würde ich sagen
sind die zielführend und ich habe keine
anderen Vorschläge gehört die es
schaffen würden irgendwo entsprechend im
klimaschutzbereich ähnliche
emissionsrückgänge zu machen also von
der Seite zumindestens mal nicht auf den
ETS Handel der irgendwann mal in einigen
Jahren kommt irgendwie das wird im
nächsten Jahr nicht dazu beitragen dass
wir sie substanziell mit den CO2 Mission
runterkommen und deswegen glaube ich
wird dieser dezent hier schon bleiben
leider und das ein Fall wie jetzt das
Aus für den Verbrenner eben dann doch
nicht so kommt die ursprünglich gedacht
was bedeutet denn das dann
wer beim Verbrenner bin ich ein bisschen
entspannter weil die Automobilindustrie
hat sich sowieso schon vom Verbrenner
verabschiedet das ist nur halt ein
falsches Signal an die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die jetzt eigentlich sich auch
noch die falschen Autos kaufen das heißt
also hier könnte man den Übergang
beschleunigen die Regierung hat ja auch
Ziele für den Hochlauf der
Elektromobilität die momentan
wahrscheinlich auch nicht erreicht
werden deswegen wäre ein klares Signal
an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
Europäische Union hat verstanden wichtig
dass wir ein gutes Signal auch für die
Industrie dass sie sich darauf
einstellen kann so Schaden wäre
Industrie und den Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aber das Verbrenner aus wird sowieso
kommen nur bei den Heizungen die haben
halt bis zu 30 Jahre Lebensdauer in den
Häusern und da dürfen eigentlich sofort
entscheiden und deswegen glaube ich ist
da diese Entscheidung auch richtig und
gut momentan bräuchten wir
mehrfachkräfte um das alles umzusetzen
das ist das was sie Ausrede sind sie
schon mal einig okay übrigens ein Punkt
haben wir wo sie sich einig sind alles
andere ist hier glaube ich auch sehr
kritisch vielen Dank für die Diskussion
Frau
Schimke und der Hübner morgen ist
Frauentag für alle aber nur in Berlin
ist das ein Feiertag
wir arbeiten aber trotzdem und wir
schauen morgen auf die Frauen im Iran
die tapfer protestieren und ja sehr
schwer unter diesem Regime leiden wir
fragen Proteste und Atomstreit wie
umgehen mit Iran ich freue mich wenn sie
wieder dabei sind und jetzt gibt's
Phoenix der Tag mit Thomas Bade bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]